hi i'm nicholas cage and this is the
wired autocomplete interview
[Music]
what do i find out when i google myself
well usually something that i i know is
not true and i usually have to call
somebody to let them know that i am not
an imposter who is taking money from
someone in england those are the reasons
why it's a good idea to do it but it is
a slippery slope you can get your
feelings hurt
oh so i gotta go like that
okay what is your favorite nicholas cage
film and why my favorite nicholas cage
film is pig i thought it was like a folk
song i thought it was like a haiku i
felt that in that movie
i had become seasoned and i had entered
the room what's the hardest role you've
ever done the hardest role i've ever
done would be the one that i'm talking
about massive talent to play yourself
or some version of so-called nic cage in
a
comedy
was a bit of a high wire act for me what
car does nicholas cage drive and gone in
60 seconds in that movie i was driving a
shelby gt500 from the 60s it's a famous
car by the name of eleanor now
i did do my own stunts in that i did go
to uh high performance driving school
and i was working with johnny martin on
that and we were doing the
360s and the donuts and
the whole kitten caboodle what does
nicholas cage want to be called you can
just call me
nick or nicholas or nikki you know what
is nicholas cage
what is nicholas cage's dream roll i'm
gonna add an apostrophe s my dream role
i like the idea of playing uh captain
nemo from jules burns 20 000 leagues
under the sea i love the ocean he loved
the ocean no acting please what did
nicholas cage steal in national treasure
as ben gates i stole the declaration of
independence imagine that
kaboom why why nicholas cage i don't
know why you tell me why why did
nicholas cage change his name i changed
my name because i was doing a little
movie called fast times at ridgemont
high and i was still nicholas copeland
people would not stop saying things like
i love the smell of nicholas in the
morning because of apocalypse now and
robert duvall saying i love the smell of
napalm in the morning and it made it
hard to work and i decided i don't need
this i changed it to cage it's a
combination of
luke cage from marvel comics it was a
character i liked also named powerman
and john cage the ivanka composer speaks
volumes about everything i've been up to
you ever since
why does nicholas cage drink soda in
willy's wonderland well you probably
know the answer that better than i do i
think anything that you think as to why
is a far better answer than anything i
could offer you that is your personal
connection with the character in willy's
wonderland and your personal connection
with what's in the soda can it can be
whatever you want and it will be right
why is nicholas cage missing a tooth in
moonstruck
well
i
did a movie called birdie i still had
baby teeth and i had my teeth pulled so
that the adult teeth could come in when
i did moonstruck i was still
kind of a spring chicken and the baby
teeth still had not come in yet
so there's that
ba-bomb
does nicolas cage find the pig i can't
answer that the answer is actually in
the movie but you may have another
answer for it that might be more
appropriate for your version of the
movie does nicholas cage know martial
arts i started practicing wing chun with
sifu jim lao when i was 12 years old
because i wanted to be bruce lee i've
always been fascinated by the
choreography if you will of martial arts
all martial arts but i don't practice
anymore did nicholas cage go upstairs at
graceland that is not
any of your business did nicholas cage
buy a pyramid that is not any of your
business did nicholas cage win an oscar
for leaving las vegas i don't know did i
how old were nicholas cage and cher in
moonstruck i
don't really know i i think i was in my
early 20s and i don't know how old cher
was how did nicholas cage get a
two-headed snake
yeah that was very strange
um i had been having strange dreams
about two-headed eagles and i this is a
true story somebody contacted my agency
and said oh there's a person that found
a two-headed snake in norwalk the next
day isn't that weird
how is nicholas cage related to francis
ford coppola well he's my my uncle how
many tattoos does nicholas cage have i
think about 12 how is nicholas cage
doing i'm doing great
is nicholas cage
is nicholas cage in fast times at
ridgemont high about that much i never
lied about my age when i was auditioning
for the part but i was auditioning for
judge reinhold's character and he was
great in the movie he's a really good
actor they thought they couldn't work
with me the hours they wanted because i
was too young they reduced me to brad's
bud number two and that's probably a
good thing is nicholas cage a pilot i am
not a pilot i wish i had i was a pilot
but i am not a pilot
is nicholas cage a method actor
it depends upon the method
is nicholas cage a genius i could never
answer that that's you answer i don't
know what i am is nicholas cage a nice
guy i hope so i i try to be i aspire to
be
oh i did oh is nicholas cage goth i like
a bit of mist in the morning and i like
being um
in england when the fog rolls in and uh
i like edgar allan poe and i like mary
shelley and i like gothic architecture
and so yeah there is a strong goth
element in some of my tastes
can
can nicolas cage can nicholas cage
shall i guess what it is before i open
it can nicholas cage sing
see telepathy sometimes i sing i used to
go in karaoke and that's fun i find it
relaxing but i wouldn't say i'm a
professional singer by any stretch of
the imagination can nicholas cage play
the mandolin well i did play the
mandolin and captain corelli's
mandolin however that was like an
immersion of
learning these two songs and i have
subsequently forgotten entirely how to
play the mandolin can nicholas cage
speak russian i cannot speak russian can
nicholas cage swim i can swim i love
swimming swimming is one of my favorite
things to do
hey
here we are it's the final board are you
ready what is nicholas cage's next movie
right now i'm currently working on a
movie called renfield which uh is
exciting nicholas holt plays renfield
and i'm supporting him in the role of
dracula movie where nicholas cage sees
the future
was called next i also liked that movie
i think that movie was pretty good will
nicholas cage be in the mcu i have no
idea
how many nicholas cage movies have you
seen uh well i've seen them all because
they're all my children and i like to
view them and then release them into the
world as you know i'm not on any social
media so this is new for me and
i hope it was as enjoyable for you as it
was for me and thank you